[Applause]
it's been a year of extreme weather
events in all corners of the globe
but ahead of the cop26 climate summit
greta tunberg is zeroing in on the uk
so i'm really hoping that we will stop
referring to the uk as a climate leader
because if you look at the reality that
is simply not true the government says
it's made big strides towards reaching
net zero the uk has been able to cut our
own co2 emissions by about 42 percent on
1990 levels but the young activists
calls that claim into question
there is a lie
that the uk has is a climate leader and
that they have reduced their co2
emissions by 44 since 1990 or whatever
and of course if you don't include all
emissions that's
of course the
statistics are going to look much nicer
but if you include things like aviation
shipping outsourcing in the
um imports of
like consumption for instance and the
burning of biomass it doesn't really
look that good she was speaking at the
launch of a new unicef report it finds
almost half the world's children living
countries classed as being at extremely
high risk of climate change impacts
it says 2 billion children are highly
exposed to air pollution 920 million are
highly exposed to water scarcity
and 820 million to heat waves
the report coincides with the third
anniversary of greta's first fridays for
future school strike
a movement which started with a single
child has since been joined by millions
more
activists like greta say children are
the biggest victims of climate change
and it's the adults at cop26 who need to
lead the fight against it
jemima walker sky news